grafton street is Dublin's main shopping
district it's also the home base of one
of Ireland's oldest and most famous
establishments Bewley's oriental cafe
Podrick Oh gallaher wants to meet here
for a full irish breakfast with eggs
grilled bacon and sausage the works we
first met the native Irishman about two
and a half years ago that's when we shot
this report
back then we visited o'kelleher at his
own restaurant gala hers box teahouse
recognized for more than 20 years as a
home of traditional Irish food hero
gallaher showed us how to make an
authentic Irish stew
you said on that report that food is
your love it's a passion is it still
like that very much so yeah yeah always
has been always will be I get up in the
morning every morning building my work
you know that's what's special about it
you know 16 hour a day for me and eight
hour days half day Oh gallaher is now
president of the restaurant association
of ireland he enjoys promoting the city
of over 1 million people and its many
landmarks
our first stop is one of dublin's
biggest tourist attractions trinity
college founded in 1592 its old library
houses one of the most important books
of the Middle Ages the Book of Kells is
a ninth-century gospel manuscript that's
famous throughout the world photography
and filming are not allowed so we have
to make do with the display photos for
many Irish their Celtic heritage and
Gaelic language are still important it's
a very old language we only have 18
letters in our language so it's quite
different as gia get means hello and
Ashley translation that is God be with
you it was decreed a an official
language of the EU a number of years ago
which will help but but it needs more
people to talk the language we continue
our journey through Ireland's history
with a stop at Dublin's oldest Cathedral
Christchurch which dates back to the
12th century we're granted exclusive
entry to the 48 meter high bell tower
for Podrick ogawa her it's a dream come
true he gets to ring the bells himself
we follow the River Liffey as we
continue through the city
Oh gallaher wants to show me another
Irish classic whiskey Jameson is the
country's oldest and most famous brand
the old jameson distillery offers guided
tours and after the tour visitors can
sample the whiskey unlike Scottish
whiskey which is distilled twice the
Irish brand is distilled three times how
important is whiskey for Irish people
it's ishka bahe a scale yet which means
the water of life it's two words that
someone ought up since drinking on an
empty stomach may not be a good idea we
head to a gala hers restaurant boxty
house it's set in the colorful Temple
Bar quarter the restaurant with its
traditional Irish cuisine has become a
tourist magnet but the economic crisis
has left a few scars the past five years
has been dramatic in the whole country
my trade is falling out sixty percent
between seven and nine and for every
night but you know you've got the rest
of the day to fill in as well but
everything is falling back here
completely we have a lot of tourists in
this area in Temple Bar so let's pet
squid
the chef's hopes that even more tourists
will come to Dublin the city already
attracts some 7 million a year and
that's evident here Temple Bar really
comes to life in the evenings Oh
gallaher thinks Dublin is the best place
to live in Ireland what do you like the
most about Dublin the people the people
are wonderful there really are I'm not
from Dublin originally I'm from the
northwest of the country County later
and nobody cares where you from the top
up you know it's not it's open it sits
at the atmosphere is really good the
bars are right that's something Patrick
ocala her personally wants to prove to
me himself in the city's most famous bar
the temple bar pub so we end the day as
any authentic day in the Irish capital
should end with a pint of Guinness and
live irish music ah